there are an infinite number of seats in
the theater of Happiness so we in our
minds have started to believe that every
we think now if you're booking a cinema
theater or a movie theater there's a
finite number of seats you got to get
tickets to the Olympics there's a finite
number of seats there's tickets to the
uh Coachella whatever it is it's like
there's a finite number of seats and so
that finite finite finite finite has
been drilled so deeply into us but there
are infinite number of seats and there's
a seat with your name on it in the
theater of happiness and just because
I'm already in there doesn't mean you
can't be in there just because you're in
there doesn't mean I can't be in there
and as soon as you realize that you free
yourself from realizing there is a seat
with your name on it and and all you've
got to do is claim your own seat and no
one else can take that seat from you and
when you start living like that you can
collaborate you can grow together you
can build together